foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar from Soup
To Nuts the Journey of a sample through
an automated automated clinical
microbiology lab I am Kaylee Bach of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by BD to learn more please visit bd.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Marco jansen's head of the laboratory
clinical microbiology of the Saint
Elizabeth Hospital tillberg in the
Netherlands Marco you may now begin your
presentation
okay thank you and welcome everybody
um to be honest it's it's a new
experience for me to sit in front of a
presentation screen not seeing the
audience but we'll see how things go so
um I will take you on our journey in in
let's say becoming a more efficient lab
and and as you can see in the title
where we try to keep all the samples on
the move and first I like to kick off
with a few old data and as you can see
many years ago our lab processed about
50 000 samples and for that we had a
33.5
FTE on formation
if we look at today
we process about 75 000 samples and only
with 15.3 FTE so you can see that we
increased the number of samples with 50
percent
and we decreased the number of Staff
with more than 50 percent
if you look at those numbers the only
conclusion for me is we have to have
become more efficient
and becoming more efficient started in
fact for us in the year 2006 where we
came in contact with the principles of
lean
and probably you all know about lean the
two major objects in in clean in in lean
is try to eliminate waste in your
process and create flow
and in 2006
if we speak about waste at that time
only seven types of waste were were yeah
were let's say available nowadays uh
fortunately there is one more and I
think that's the main the main thing or
the most important thing
um the brain of
yeah of you all so now we have eight
types of ways if you don't use the brain
well then you have a big problem
so we learned a lot about lean and and
try to
look at all these types of waste and and
at a certain time we came to the point
okay what can we do to make our life
easier
and I will not bother you with all the
things that we did on the lab since that
time but I I can tell you that
well it it goes into a hundreds of
improvements that we did to let's let's
say to make our life easier and to get
our process uh in better shape
doing that
we still got a lot of ways left over and
in microbiology plate handling is one of
the major things in in forms of waste
and as staff lab staff we like to walk
around there are a lot of movements
going around on the lab and I have a
slide for you where we videotaped one
technician only defeat of course and we
followed that technician for 22 minutes
and as you can see that person has
walked 300
54 meters so in fact we we were very
good employees so you get paid to get
physically fit
but of course it takes a lot of time and
a lot of waste in this case
um
then we came to a point that
we'd already did a lot of improvements
but we tried to move to the
organizations
the organization towards lab automation
for two major reasons
first of all the Improvement of quality
you try to have a full traceable process
and a very important thing in processes
is standardization
and the other thing why we want to move
towards lab automation is efficiency
would it be possible to handle a plate
only when it's necessary that it needs
when it needs work
then we came to the implementation of
our total lab Automation and that
started already in 2006 in the same year
that we Sorry came in contact with uh
the lean principle we also came in
contact with the company keystra at that
time we discussed with them the
possibilities of total lab automation
and keystra did a quick scan of the lab
and one of the things that came out of
the quick scan that our lab had an LPI
of 14.4 and LPI stands for the number of
samples per FTE per day
so there was this number and at that
point for me that number had no meaning
at all I had no clue if this was good
bad or averaged
so okay the number was there
so as you can see it took us quite a
while to sign the contract
uh that was done in 2009 then in January
2010
uh keystra started building up the the
instrument and in February 2010 we
started training our technicians
and then
halfway of March we could start with the
implementation and there we had a little
disagreement with with tisra at that
time
at that time Division if you start with
one or two easy sample categories
and you process them for four to eight
weeks if that goes well go on to the
next two sample categories
Etc
if you do it like this implementation
would take several months
we already learned a lot about lean and
we know that
when we started with lab automation we
had to make a lot of settings in the
system
so
then came our occasion hey you know if
you make settings yourself you make
mistakes so our idea was if we start
with five samples per sample category
per day
and we process them for one week
then there is a reasonable chance that
all the mistakes that we made
are well let's say discovered after one
week
if that is the case we could go on and
double our uh process with 10 samples
per sample category per day
and do that for two weeks so this is how
we get our implementation
and the outcome was that we started on
March the 14th
and we had a full implementation and
it's not a joke on April the 1st of 2010
so it took us only two and a half weeks
for a full implementation of our lab
automation
of course
you come to the question what is the
best way then
to be honest I don't have the answer and
probably the answer is somewhere
in in between in the middle
and this is the system where we started
with in 2010 and it even had a very nice
name it's the sample that moves and as
you can see we started with only one
first generation incubator
eight workbenches and a part where the
plates are stored
so what was at that time the impact on
our process
okay we didn't have to label the dishes
anymore manually and in that time it was
this number three and a half to five
thousand dishes per week
but the major thing
was that we didn't have to handle all
the plates anymore and if you look at
this number
closely you see that only 20 of all the
place that we put in the system
were used for let's say culture
proceeding so we have an 80 reduction of
plate handling
and if you would do on your own lab
let's say
um just measurements of how much time is
spent on plate handling then you will
realize that 80 reduction is a huge
amount of time
of course we didn't have to walk around
as much as we did because the plates
went automatically to the incubator and
from the incubator to the workbench only
our plates that were not incubated in
the system okay we have to pick them out
of the incubator put them on the track
and then get a picture
and for the patient of course our
results were earlier available but
because
from 2010
till today the average reading time
is still between 30 and 40 seconds per
sample
so for instance an easy cameras a
culture might take me one or two seconds
to read and a difficult puss perhaps a
minute and a half but on average
it has been for 12 and a half years now
between 30 and 40 seconds which is
pretty quick I think
we come back to the LPI
remember that we started in 2006 with an
LPI of 14.4
we start installing lab Automation and
as you can see
working two years with lab automation
we increased the LPI the productivity
with more than 90 percent which is well
almost doubled
even to become better and and well
um
there were developments during these
first years that we worked with lab
automation
so at a certain time a second generation
incubators was
um was built so we invested in
uh two new uh second generation
incubators
and we invested in
in inocular and then an automated
inoculation machine
so nobody has to
do the inoculation manually anymore
and another Advantage with
this type of inoculation is you see it
on the left
top of the screen
you see a picture of a plate and I think
each lab have sometimes these examples
somebody tried to imitate the Zorro uh
signature I think
it means you have a culture with with
well where you can do nothing with you
have to redo it the next day
using the machine it's always the same
streaking pattern with always the same
high quality result and single color
needs to work with
doing that should should have an effect
also on the LPI and as you can see on
the right side of the slide you see that
we
install the inocular Ender two they are
called reader compacts in 2014 and again
an increase of LPI of 27 percent
we want to do
oh this is that's the next slide of
course a clinical impact
um
we think quality improved because you
haven't
uh a process that you can follow from
the first to the last step
because everything is locked in your
system
another advantage of
working like this is you can always have
a review
if you are a manual lab and a technician
decides to
throw away the pledge because that
technician thinks we're done
okay your evidence is gone
with lab automation of course you can
throw away the plates physically but no
one can throw away the picture so if
necessary you can always have a look
back on
how was it with this specific culture
and another important thing because you
have a decrease of turnaround time
a patient can be treated in an earlier
stage
it wasn't enough for us so
we we kept thinking about the future at
that time and
I will show you a graph
and I try to explain it to you
um the red line is the number of samples
that is ready for reading at that time
and as you can see
um we were a lab that worked only
daytime
so you see
during the night
hundreds of samples are just waiting
and we also know that waiting is well
one of the top forms of waste
the green line
that's the lab technicians that's
that's the line that says how many
samples did you read
as you can see we have a huge gap
between the number of samples ready and
waiting
and
when they are red
and in our opinion the only thing to
solve this problem is
we have to go to a 24 7 schedule
and that is what we did at that time and
that was in 2014.
doing that
must have effects on the entire process
and now I will show you a few different
slides about different steps in the
process and the effects of 24 7 compared
to let's say a regular day schedule
as you can see this is a graph that
shows the workload in first inoculation
so setting up new samples and as you can
see
our day was filled with huge Peaks
so if you would ask a technician how are
you doing they were always busy
looking at the same graph but then in a
24 7 schedule you see
of course there are Peaks you will never
get the ideal straight line but you can
see that the Peaks are much lower than
before so if you would visit that lap
the lab at that time you saw the people
not being stressed
of course after
inoculation we have to start reading and
as you can see when we entered the lab
at eight
of course we just saw hundreds of
samples were ready for reading so we
started with a enormous Peak
in in in work
of reading samples and of course during
the day a bit lower but they were still
there
we look at that in a 24 7 schedule
you can read all day and each each Mark
in the graph stands for a 15 minute
timestamp
well if you have a high peak in the
morning for reading
we know that a few hours later you have
the enormous peak in
doing follow-up work
and also
in a 24 7 schedule
almost
every Peak is is well
almost gone
so if you combine all these graphs you
see that our days were filled with high
peaks of workload so yes we were having
the feeling that we were very very busy
and that it was always too much work for
the group that has to work
and in the 24 7 you see
we can just go on doing work
throughout the entire 24 hours
if we go back to the
graph that I just showed you and that's
the one on the left
on the left corner
that was the one with the big gap and
the waiting time
if you look to the right corner you will
see that the red and the green line
are almost on top of each other which in
fact means if your sample is ready for
reading we read it
if you do it like this
it must have an effect on your
turnaround time
on your cultures and these are just a
few Sam examples of different
protocols that we had at the those days
and you see
the enormous decrease in turnaround time
of those different protocols
but we want we want more because more is
developed so we want more we want to
improve more become better become more
efficient
so at a certain time the Yucca the urine
culture app was developed which is a
software application
um to sort out your negative urines from
your presumptive positive ones
of from which
as a final result you could
automatically send out your negative
results so that means that for instance
your no growth urines
should not be seen any more by any
technicians
so that only leaves
the urines with growth on it that needs
attention from A lab technician
a few years ago identified came into the
lab identify is the automated uh
machine that that prepares the
multi-target plates
for you
and I will come back to this one later
a year before identify came a new
software platform was introduced
synapses and
the last
uh slides of these of this they will be
a total focus on synapses
and then of course
applications for amerisiviri CBE espl
and the last thing and that's the one
that I would like to have is an
application for growth monitoring for
sterile samples
just to make sure that the most
important samples that we have are
monitored by a software application that
will notify me if there is growth
um going back to identify we installed
it three years ago so when we read
plates plates will automatically go and
we need identification they will
automatically go to identify identify or
prepare a suspension prepare the
multi-target plate and then the only
thing we have to do is put the
multi-target in
um in in the multi-top itself
another thing that the identifier can do
is
because It prepares a heavy suspension
to prepare the multi-target
but it can also dilute this heavy
suspension back to 0.5 McFarland
suspension
the suspension is made in deionized
water
and wouldn't it be nice if we could use
the 0.5 McFarlane suspension
to set up
the AST the Phoenix panels so right now
we are working uh on a validation
uh on that subject so as you can see in
the slide it starts with a uh with a
plate with with markings on it
they first go to identify in identify it
will get the let's say the plus four
McFarland suspension from which the
multi-target is uh is prepared and then
measured in the mold It Off
from the heavy suspension
identify well dilute it back to a 0.5
McFarland we inoculate the broth with
that
set up a phoenix panel put it in the
Phoenix
and then compare these results with the
normal lap routine which is on the
bottom of the slide
the the same plate will take the
identify route but also
the next step is to go to the workbench
on the workbench we prepare the
suspension put the suspension in the
Phoenix AP to get the correct dilution
inoculate the Phoenix panel and put it
in the Phoenix
we're about uh three quarter now of the
total that that we want to test
and a few weeks ago we already submitted
an abstract
on the preliminary results of these two
methods and
uh okay it's not final yet but let's say
it's looking very good
so
we started in 2010 with this
TLA
in 2014 we in replaced the first
generation incubator for two second
generation incubator and we installed
the inocula
and nowadays
it's a system with an extra incubator
just because we got more work and
the identify connected to the track
my next
series of slides
is about synapses the new software
platform well the software platform that
was released about four years ago
um we started as well we were the first
in Europe to have it and we started at
the same time with two American Labs
um
I will just take you through the
different screens of synapses and
hopefully I can give you a good
impression of
how it works what it does for you
I was going to do it live but
the
how do you say it the firewalls in the
hospital
does not allow to to well
to enter all these things so so I have
to do it with slides
um opening synapses it's it always
starts with a personalized dashboard and
as you can see I have quite a lot on my
dashboard
the graphs are more for my fun
on the left side that's more
um let's say
to give me a good view of where we are
and how the process is going and if I as
a as a lab manager need to do anything
about step do do I need extra staff on
certain steps or not it starts with with
a series of quick links to Quick links
just to go to different modes in
synapses
underneath that
a small table with an overview that says
ready for reading schedule which is
nothing more than
an overview that tells you how many
samples are ready for reading at this
time
and how many samples will become ready
in the next few hours
the one on the right side of the quick
links is the workload status of
the different types of follow-up work
that we defined it's all about how you
define your work well we defined several
types of culture workup
and as you can see in this table
for type of skill of workup the number
of plates that are well that needs to be
processed by that specific lab
technician
and finally I have an overview of the
number of uh ID results are available
for review if we use identifier for
identification
all the results are sent to synapses to
get a review so you can send them I have
to review to your Lis and well
confirmate the result over there
um if we go to the first step in
synapses which is culture inoculation
we come to a screen that we use the
least
because this is
um
a screen that is used for samples that
you
inoculate completely manual
and as I already explained we have an uh
inocula and inocular has a full
automatic side and a semi-automatic side
so for us it means
we put as much as possible in the full
automatic size and the samples that
cannot be processed either fa side we
process them semi-automatic so only the
samples
that cannot be processed
by the inocula and well you can think
for instance on the tip of a catheter
it it you you need to roll it over a
plate so that cannot be done by the
inocula that is done in this mode so I
think for me on my lap
perhaps three samples per day in this
mode
um
when you have the sample and you scan
your sample ID
the information
from the Lis is sent to synapses and now
you can see okay you need to inoculate
these different plates or tubes whatever
it takes you request the plate you
inoculate the plate and then tell okay
I'm done and from that point
uh all your media will get the status
that they are inoculated
if we go to the second quick link which
is culture reading you see in uh in in
my case you see quite a lot of different
work lists
and a work list is nothing more than
than a list of samples
with all the
um how do you say that well no the
criteria for a list are made by you so
in my case
most of the lists well all the lists are
based on uh sample type
but if for instance on your lap you want
to have a specialist
for ICU specimens as long as your Lis
can send that information to synapses
you can use it to create
your own uh word list for that
so we have the different
categories and there is always I'm
afraid it's in Dutch there is always one
work list that says oh cultures ready
for reading
because you can imagine in the beginning
of the day you start working based on
okay I start with urines then I go to
that but later on when when you only
have a few samples in each folder or in
each work list you switch to the all
list and then work them one by one
so what I did in the work list culture
reading I just opened uh a urine culture
and as you can see uh in the screen
and I blurred it out because it will
provide you with some patient
demographics
on the left side and on above that with
the barcode on it it's the sample number
and in this case we have a urine culture
with two plates
and I choose a urine as an example
because you can also see what the urine
culture app
uh does for us on the right hand corner
of each
uh picture
you see some texts one of them
the the Top Line
is GS stands for growth score
so the software application will give me
a growth score of this specific plate
the second thing that the software
application does for you it will give
you
um
let's say a purity
um comment I would say so in
in the software there are three
possibilities to get your pure decomment
which is
like like here it's pure and pure means
in the software more than 99
of all the growth on the plate is one
type
the second thing the software can tell
you that it's predominant
and predominant is
uh between 90 and 99
one type
and if it's not Pure or predominant it
will be called uh complex
and then we have a third
thing on the screen of the chromoganic
media
there's this sort of microorganism and
if you hover over it with the mouse
you can see on the screen it will give
me a presumptive ID
though in this case it's an E coli but
the software can also give you uh
the PMP Group which stands for products
morganella or Providencia
guest Group which stands for klebsiella
and robot or Sriracha group
it can tell you if a staff separate
predicus is in it uh threat B is in it
enterococcus species and if it's not one
of those six it will tell you it's other
we go on to the next because the next
step is okay I want to do something with
this culture
and as you can see I marked
five colonies and
it's always when you use identify you
always Mark several con sub colonies
three the five colonies depending on the
size because
identify wants to uh to create a heavy
suspension you can imagine that with a
small Colony one colony is not enough to
create a heavy suspension
so you mark three to five of the same
colonies
and then on the right side
the only thing you have to do is
under the
under the header organism name
we fill in a sort of presenter of ID so
in my case I just filled in it looks
like a gram-negative
and at the quantity spot you fill in the
quantity
and if the quantity is measured by the
urine culture app it will be filled in
automatically
just by choosing my presumptive ID it
looks like a gram-negative
and under uh
on the lower side on the right side I
will get different protocols to choose
from
well my standard protocol is always
combined with an automated maldi so I've
choose I've chosen the
standard protocol
and a bit above you can see by the order
test okay I requested a purely plate
because I also want to
set up an AST and I ordered an automated
maldi
so when I've done that I would press the
button Mark as read
and then from that moment on this marked
plate will get the signal okay now you
can go to identify so without
manual requests by anyone the plate will
be sent to identify to get is uh Baldi
and the software will go on to the next
sample that is ready for reading
looking at this
um because I told you with the
urine culture app that it's it separates
the negatives from the presumptive
positives well in this case my negatives
are still being well put in a yeah in a
sort of work list
for me to check
so I don't send out negative results
automatically yet but that's to come
um so in this case as you can see in my
Pro active out of verification list
there are two samples for me to verify
that the application was right
so just by pressing it I will come into
this screen and
I just look at okay I see negative
plates also the growth score is less
than 100 cfu per mil so the only thing I
have to do now is on the right side on
the screen
is press the button accept and then my
code for a negative result is sent to my
Lis and sent automatically to the
physician
the
third mode in synapses is about culture
workup
and culture workup is nothing more than
I told I showed you the the table with
the different types of workup well
the technician that is responsible for
specific workup
you can see in its screen okay there are
places for me to be processed
the technician request plates to the
workbench when the plate arrives at the
workbench
you just scan the barcode on the side of
the plate and then you will get the
picture of that specific plate and that
is the biggest difference in screen
between
a workup screen and a reading screen in
a reading screen everybody sees all the
plates of that sample in a workup screen
you only see the picture of the plate
that needs workup
and if you look closely at the picture
you see five markings on it of which
three are marked black
the black marked colonies that means
that the inocula only used three of the
five marked colonies to create the heavy
suspension
identify will pick a few colonies create
the suspension measure the suspension if
it's high enough it will stop picking if
it's not high enough it will continue to
use the other colonies that you marked
so in this case we scan the barcode we
get the picture and on the right side I
can see
what type of work do I have to do
after doing it the technician
presses the button okay I've done it and
again everything will be locked so you
know exactly which technician has done
what at what time
then finally if we have the molly
you still want to check okay before
you're not sending out automatically all
the results so there is this ID AST
review list
opening
that quick link you also see different
work lists
one with the all isolate ready for
review needs attention well the needs
attention might be the ones that has a
score which is not high enough so
we just opened
the list and this is what you see then
again the patient demographics on the
left side with of course the sample
number
and
we see
let's say the top 10 of this specific
uh
strain
but you also see and that's a bit above
the the table of the top ten you see the
turbidity that was measured by identify
so if we agree with this result and we
want to send it to the Lis
use the button mark
Mark has reviewed and sent to Lis
just by pressing that
it will send the result to the Lis and
the next
uh isolate to be checked will be
presented in your screen
and now I hope that I gave you a good
impression of what we have what we do
and
what we are trying to do in the future
so
I think we're
we're there
great well thank you Marco for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
so let's get started our first question
asks what part of automation do you
think is enabling you to achieve faster
turnaround times
uh I think if I look at the last 12
years then uh I think all parts
are
well not all perhaps not all necessary
but if you really
um
look at all the different parts then I
would say
that all parts are more or less even
valuable to to achieve this
so what I mean is is
the fast incubators the automatic
inoculation of course of the samples the
identify that that is doing its work
while you are doing some other work
so so yes I think I think all the parts
are equally valuable for this
great thank you another question we have
here what is the value of identify for
your lab
uh identify make sure that that first of
all I uh I I have a continuous process
like I said when people are reading
identifies doing the work while other
people are reading and
it's it's a very standardized method and
and I don't have exact data in in how
much better identifier
um
creates multi-targets compared to manual
but
I I just know that let's say the number
of
um
green moldy spots a maldi uh results com
from identify compared to
um the manual ones is is yeah identify
it's much higher
and I want to thank our audience for
these great questions they're submitting
here we'll go ahead and continue with
this next question this asks what are
the qualitative non-measurable benefits
of identify
um yeah non-measurable uh like I said
the the the the the the number or the
percentage of
uh Maldives that that that gives a very
good result a high result is much higher
higher than than with the manual method
and to be honest we never measured
um when we didn't have identify we never
measured
how many Maldives do we have to redo
because well someone perhaps did not did
a good job so exact numbers are not
available but
um
you know the the feeling and and and
just seeing it uh we just know that that
uh it's it's a much higher quality
right now Marco what is your staff's
opinion about identify and how is
identify adding value to their
day-to-day work in the lab
um well that's more or less the the same
answer for it's also for the staff that
they see that that it's a continuous
process and they are already used to
focus on what can we do to improve our
processes so for them identify fits fits
very well in in
in in the mindset of
becoming more efficient and and getting
better results because it's a
combination of both
and and of course they see it they feel
it they they
realize that that's not a lot of
Maldives have to be
uh done again by by by someone else so
it's for them it's a sort of yeah
um it it really fits
the the way we were used to think and
the way we used to work
great we have another question to this
regard how did the older staff take to
the new way of reading cultures yeah
that's a good one
um
it's it's
uh
it it was it was a let's say a hard way
of learning
and not not only the older ones but uh I
I understand the question of course it's
not easy for someone that has been doing
reading let's say manually for 25 years
and then have to trust a picture
so what we did is is first of all
tell everybody if you don't trust the
picture
just press the button and the plate will
be brought to your workbench
because it's not me that can convince
the staff the only person that can
convince you is yourself so
when we started I think
well let's say 25 to 50 plates per day
were requested to a workbench by
technicians just to make sure that what
they saw on a screen was reality
if I think nowadays
I don't know I don't even know if if we
come to to account of five for that
purpose
so it's more a matter of
um
getting
trying to get everybody to feel
comfortable with it and
when we started we also said okay just
give it a year it's it wouldn't be fair
to
um to try
let's say within a month
everybody to feel comfortable that for
we we thought that that wouldn't be fair
so we just took a year and and
yeah after a year I I could say okay now
I'm sure that everybody in its own way
because it's still
it's still it's still technique
and again not everybody has the same
feeling with technique so that's also
the thing that that yeah comes along
with it
but now everybody is yeah everybody can
can work very good with it so
um there is no
in fact there is no thing that that
holds people back because they know if I
don't trust it okay I just request the
plate within a minute it's it's on your
workbench
great thank you Marco we have time for a
few more questions here this next is a
two-part question and it asks do you
process positive blood cultures in
keystra and how do you transfer samples
from the bottle to place in keystra
uh yes we process them on the system and
what we do is we have these uh venting
units so we uh we put a vending unit
uh through the cap of the of the blob
bottle and we process those bottles on
the semi-automated part so we scanned
the bottle plates are being brought just
in front of you we put a drop of blood
on each plate they'll be street by the
inocula and then they are
well they go to the to the incubators
great this next question asks what
advice would you provide for labs
considering automation
I think
the
let's say for me the most important
thing is if you switch from manual to
lab automation
forget what you did Manual
and create a complete new process with
the knowledge that you have
what you can do with lab automation I am
convinced that if people invest a lot of
money in lab automation
and you put your manual way
in the lab automation it's not going to
be a success
right and that answer was a great segue
to our next question here before the
introduction of automatic reading was
there a comparative measurement of the
efficiency of manual reading in
automatic reading
uh to be honest no because
um it it was for us let's say uh being
focused on efficiency
and introducing lab automation came more
or less at the same time so
when we came in contact with the lean
principles in 2006 for us that was the
moment
to to become really
um focused on okay we are doing our work
for so many years in a certain way and
nobody thought
about it can we do it better or whatever
unless we were triggered by well this
phenomenon
that
focus on on your process and focus be
honest
on your be honest to your own process
that perhaps some steps can be improved
that's you you don't have to be ashamed
about it it's it's more a matter of am I
am I willing to see
that some steps that I make
can be done better or more efficient
right and it looks like we have time for
one more question here so we'll go ahead
and wrap up with this one has there been
Improvement in patient discharge time or
ICU time because of faster turnaround
time of results
yeah that's that's also a hard one and
again to be honest I I once spoke with
one of the I believe the Canadian ladies
of BD and and
we discussed okay would it be possible
to get all these measurements in to
answer this question and
to be honest it it is so difficult to
really focus on okay what happens if I
send out my final result
half a day earlier
is the discharge pure based on my
earlier result or is it a combination of
my earlier result
combined with perhaps some other things
so we never
dug into it because it it's really so
much work to figure it out but
again my heart says yes it it must have
an effect on on on this charge it it
I think there is no other way
great and Marco we're going to squeeze
one more question in here this last
question asked was there a reduction in
the number of Staff as a result of the
automation of work processes
uh that's a yes and that's a no uh if
the question means did you fire anyone
when you introduced uh live automation
the answer is no
um
but when we uh knew that we were going
into lab Automation and we learned a lot
about lean we already
optimized so many processes that each
time for instance A lab technician
wanted to go work part-time or a lab
technician left the lab that we didn't
filled in those empty spots because it
wasn't necessary anymore so my more than
50 percent decrease what I showed in one
of the first slide of staff is pure
based on let's say natural uh yeah are
you say that in English natural causes
or
um it is what it was a natural process
and and no one was fired because of this
great
well that brings us to the end of our
session so thank you again Marco for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to think of
labyrinths and our sponsor BD for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye